you and gene Simmons of kiss of all
people gene says hey wait a second NWA
isn't rock and roll and kind of alluded
to the fact on Twitter that you guys
shouldn't have been inducted am I
correct on that yeah I think so I think
he believes just straight for rock and
rollers and you know I got a lot of
respect for gene Simmons you know I met
him couple of times he's actually pretty
cool right I just think he's wrong on
this but isn't it weird to argue this
out on Twitter with Jesus and Jesus it's
very weird
gene says gene Gina hit me up on Twitter
gene says I'm looking forward to the
death of rap fan gene tweeted to you
yeah Ice Cube respectfully let me know
when Jimi Hendrix gets into the hip-hop
Hall of Fame then you'll have a point
first of all I don't even think there is
a definitely not on the level of the
Hall of Fame if it is one and you guys
are going back and forth out it he's old
G in the game but he's just wrong on
this you know it's a spirit you know and
it's been going on before they called it
rock and roll in other words you're a
guy just like any rock and roller who
started out not with a lot in life and
you had to struggle your way into the
music industry and you came up and yeah
maybe you're rapping but you're rocking
and rolling actually you're an innovator
you look took the music to another level
right someplace else it had been in one
spot for a long time now ain't that rock
and roll now who would win in a physical
fight you would you change got to hide
on you he does look at the range
he's got the reach but you I feel you
have the street-smart
yeah you got that Tyson inside it's
right just get going rich but not you
know gene like I say he's og absolutely
we in baby yep you're into it you're a
Rock and Roll Hall of Famer get used to